appropriate linguistically comfortable
way reaching out to the community
especially poignant at this time of aapi
violence hate crimes that are happening
in our country
it was wonderful to be with them and to
see what a model they are
to the country in reaching out to
previously underserved communities when
it comes to
this vaccine the virus and administering
this vaccine
they will be beneficiaries they are
beneficiaries
of the package the rescue package and
that was my honor to compliment them
on the work that they are doing but
again
all over the country members are
reaching out to community groups
who have the confidence of the members
of their communities
in order to make sure that they avail
themselves of the benefits
of the rescue package
in terms of saving lives i'm so proud of
what president biden
presented this morning uh addressing
the epidemic of gun violence in our
country
more than 41 000 americans died from gun
violence
last year the highest year on record so
far
with the most vulnerable being the women
children
communities of colors cruelly and
disproportionately affected
the steps that the president was
announcing today will save lives
stopping the spread of
ghost guns helping ensure that dangerous
people cannot access firearms
and leading an evidence-based whole of
government initiative
to reduce community violence
again we are proud in the house that we
have already passed h.r eight
in the leadership of councilman mike
thompson and his co-chairs robin kelly
and
and con and so many others who have been
working on these issues for a long time
as well as mr clyburn and h.r 14
41 closing the south carolina loophole
so necessary as we see another act of
violence in south carolina today
these bills are common sense they are
bipartisan and again over 90
of the american people support what we
are doing there
we are getting ready now of course for
the american jobs plan
and we had a plan that uh clearly this
country needs
you've heard me say again and again when
we talk about
building the infrastructure and creating
jobs in our country we have to think big
and transformatively
as thomas jefferson did with his first
initiative
in this regard as teddy roosevelt did
with the national park service that he
created 100 years
anniversary of what thomas jefferson did
what president eisenhower did
in the interstate highway system that he
established
in the interest of our nation's security
and now with president biden is
presenting
all-american transformative thinking
big built back better
and as we say in the house in every zip
code
in america so that everyone
has a full advantage of what the
infrastructure does it creates jobs in
the building
it creates commerce in the moving of
products who from farm to produce from
farm to
market or other products from production
to the marketplace so people to school
and work and the rest
clean air for our children clean water
for them to drink get the lead
out again and again to talk about
how we do this in a way that involves
everyone in our country
all across our country we hope to do
this in the most bipartisan way possible
infrastructure has not been a partisan
issue
in the past we hope that it would not be
now
and so again we
we don't want to do this in a way that
is ancient we wanted to do it as it is
the future
so many times you've heard people say we
want to be on the right side of
of history no we want to be on the right
side of history out but we want to be on
the right side
of the future as well so it's the
building infrastructure is a safety
measure as well the safety of our
bridges our roads
safety of the water our children drink
the list goes on
and then when we return we have a
legislative field weekly for when we
went
broke for the holy season uh we did have
a time for committee work that has
prepared us to bring legislation to the
floor
when we come back uh in this next week
but then i'd be pleased to take any
questions you may have
if you'd like to be added to the queue
to ask a question please select the
raise hand option under the reactions
tab at the bottom of your screen
one moment while we wait for reporters
to join the queue
thank you drew
while we're waiting for reporters i'm
excited about saturday but i'll be
joining the national domestic workers
alliance
is the director and in case you don't
know her she's an iconic leader
for caregivers in our country really
heroin and i'm so honored to be invited
to join
their initiative on saturday any
questions
our first question comes from eric
wassen with bloomberg news
hi speaker thanks so much for doing this
if you could tell us a little bit about
what are the next steps on this american
jobs
plan uh getting it together what
decisions you're gonna be making
and some confusion about this american
families plan is it possible
that gets wrapped into the jobs plan and
how do you see approaching that issue
thank you
thank you well it's pretty exciting uh
when we're talking about this
this next bill a few weeks ago i
uh suggested or tasked or
called upon my committee chairs
to reach across the aisle on the the
infrastructure aspects of this bill
and to see where we can find
bipartisanship because as i said this
has never been partisan
but when we go forward with this
legislation we have to
involve everyone and that means women
who are in the world
who should be participating in how we
build uh
the future of our country as well and
for that to happen
uh what was in the uh in our previous
bill in the rescue package and what will
be in
the family bill are very important when
we talk about child care elder care and
the rest
so everyone can participate so these
things are related if
if you're going to build the
infrastructure you have to have
workforce development
education is very very important in that
when we talk about
investing in education we recognize that
nothing brings more money to the
treasury
nothing than education of the american
people early childhood k-12
higher education post-grad lifetime
learning
training for our lifetime training for
our workers
so that they can build for the future so
all of these things
are related and and um uh i don't
i i think we will have two bills that we
will have this uh bill but
we're hoping that we can do especially
the infrastructure bill
where as i said now for the third time
it's always been bipartisan or
nonpartisan
uh that we will do so in a partisan in a
bipartisan way
if we have to go to reconciliation
that's a lever but i hope it's not
something that we need to do
and con the time wise uh mr mr defazio
thinks that we can
do our part in the house probably in the
month of
may at least his committee would be
ready
at that time i would hope that our part
in the house would be
largely done before the fourth of july
whether the whole package can be done
then
we just don't know but as some have
suggested we want to do it before the
august break
now our plan does have not only
infrastructure
roads mass transit water broadband
education housing it has a number
the definition of infrastructure in a
broader sense
but also how how we do it what we do
and how we do it in a way that involves
jobs
think of this as the american american
jobs plan
as we just finished the american rescue
plan
and our next question comes from lindsay
mcpherson with roll call
um related to what you said about
wanting
the bills to be bipartisan how do you
judge that
is it when the bills go to markup
whether they get any bipartisan support
is it before markup
when do you expect to make the
determination on whether it's possible
to do it in a very personal way
lindsay oh thank you i uh we want
bipartisanship every step of the way
and again we want to build consensus
within our own party
as we go forward and again many of the
projects that we're talking about
have regional significance and they are
bipartisan
in their region so we were hoping that
we can translate
the needs of the communities across the
country
which are nonpartisan into a
legislation that works for for everyone
uh
so every step of the way you know
whether it's in uh like
for example they had a committee hearing
on
electrification before the
break for holy week etc and mr
defazio presided as as chair of the
committee
mr graves there also another and
bipartisan
uh hearing the
some of one of the people testified and
i've said this i think last week in our
meeting
the head of um
fedex he said we're all we're going
electric we're going electric we think
now i'm staying separate them that we
think that the postal system will go
electric
many uh fleets will be going electric so
we need to have
the infrastructure for
recharging around the country the
distribution
of of those charging stations is
absolutely essential
uh to what we want to do to be
competitive in the world with our cars
so it's
it's about jobs in every way
and it's also about having the
infrastructure to
support the new
automobiles that we want to be
competitive and selling in the rest of
the world so that was a positive meeting
i
i didn't hear too much complaint from
the republicans
coming out of that and much of what
we want to do is going to be based on
data
which hearings will provide for us
so again based on information
facts data science
science science i think that
in the communities we'll see more common
ground than we have seen
in the congress that was true in the
rescue package
uh i hope that it is a more bipartisan
as we go into the infrastructure but
every every step of the way
and again as we were we were receiving
a briefing from secretary of the
treasury the other day
let's we're here to listen she said
we're here to listen to people's ideas
and that's across the aisle as well
within our own party
our next question comes from chris van
cleeve with cbs news
madam speaker thanks for your time i'm
curious given
what happened last friday at the capitol
in terms of security
do you feel that there needs to be a
rethinking of the fencing around the
capital
uh does there need to be an increase in
security
um or or the footprint around the
capital
um given some of the intelligence uh
that the law enforcement continues to
see
well the the there has to be a
discussion of it um
i thank you for your question we will be
preparing we
have been preparing a supplemental
to meet the security needs of the
capitol
both in terms of what needs to be done
to harden
the windows the doors etc of the capital
what is
needed in terms of increasing the size
of the capitol police force
filling uh some of the the vacancies
that are there now
over 200 uh the training that we need
uh to do the intelligence gathering that
is so important
as well as the infrastructure
other differences of opinion or some
people want no
outside structure we have a
report from general honore which i
respect the report
that can talk about some fencing
available when needed but that's all a
discussion
but the fact is is that very soon
we're going to have to pass the
supplemental
to have the funds to harden the capital
to increase the personnel uh to make
judgments
about of the fence and and people have
very definite opinions one way or
another uh
sadly friday it just was so shocking to
us here it was good friday we were just
about ready to enter into
stem as a person who was catholic into a
in
in in california into a period of uh
the most holy time and then
the sadness of it all and the
psychological impact that it has for
people who work
there and that and that's why we're so
appreciative
of the capitol police for how they have
protected us
but when we have the supplemental put
forth which will be soon
uh then we'll have a discussion as to
what happens with the fencing and the
rest and people
are listening and respectful but also
we have to be careful and none of us i
mean maybe some of us are security
experts but
most of us would have to pay attention
to those
who are security and law enforcement
leaders who have made proposals to us
it'll be soon
our next question comes from monte raju
with cnn
yes okay thanks for taking my question
uh